Hey, accidents happen. But if you're in a
movie, sometimes accidents can turn out to
be amazing. In fact, some of the most memorable
moments in cinema were actually the result of
mistakes that the filmmakers decided were too
good to leave out of the finished movie.
Alfred Hitchcock coined the term "MacGuffin"
to describe important objects upon which the
plot of a movie revolves — like
the briefcase in Pulp Fiction,
or the Infinity Stones in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe. As any comic fan will tell you,
the Infinity Stones are incredibly
important and powerful — which is
why it's so funny when Chris Pratt, as
Star-Lord, just straight up drops one.
It looks totally scripted, but according to
the DVD commentary, that was an actual moment
of clumsiness from Pratt. But the moment
works, so director James Gunn left it in.
As war looms and the loss of Rohan seems imminent,
Eowyn stares off into the distance as the camera
reveals a wide scenic shot. As she does, a
flag on a pole whips in the wind. And then,
perfectly expressing the mood of
uncertainty and destruction to come,
the flag rips off the pole and flies away.
The metaphor was not only beautifully apt,
but it was totally accidental. Director Peter
Jackson didn't plan for this — it was just
really windy on that day of shooting.
This movie made Anne Hathaway a star,
and the DVD has become a slumber party classic for
little kids. It's a classic ugly duckling story
of a girl named Mia who finds out she's the heir
apparent to a small European kingdom. But she's
so very awkward, y'see, falling down all the
time, as she learns how to carry herself with
the grace and poise befitting a royal. At one
point, Mia is dancing on some bleachers in
the rain at her private school with her best
friend when she takes a pretty nasty tumble.
That's no stuntwoman, and that
wasn't supposed to happen:
Hathaway really did slip, falling
hard. But it fit in so well with
the character's awkwardness that
it was kept in the finished film.
The idea was simple: Bond-girl rides a horse
along the beach, and Daniel Craig swims upto her.
But as he floated up, the actor ran
into a sand bank, giving him no choice but to
quickly stand up on his feet and stomp out of
the water. Suddenly, Bond is standing there,
muscled-up body on display, along
with some very revealing swim trunks.
Casino Royale was a reboot of the Bond series,
so most fans assumed this was an homage to the
classic scene from the first Bond film, Dr. No,
where Ursula Andress emerges from the ocean.
But it was actually just a lucky accident.
Indiana Jones wasn't the only raider of the
lost ark in, uh, Raiders of the Lost Ark. There
was also evil French archaeologist Rene Belloq,
who suffers a doubly horrible fate:
not only does his head explode…
...but he also eats a fly! Well, okay, not
exactly. During a closeup of actor Paul Freeman,
a fly appears to crawl right down Belloq's
throat. Freeman later revealed that the insect
actually flew away after crawling around
his lips for a moment, but some judicious
editing after the fact made it look like the
cold blooded Belloq just ate the fly instead.
The police lineup scene early in the movie
is crucial to the plot of The Usual Suspects:
it's where all the criminal main characters meet
to arrange a big heist. As each character steps
forward to read the line police told them to read,
none of them can contain their laughter, perfectly
setting up the dynamic between the characters as
well as their collective disregard for the cops.
But the laughing wasn't in the script,
and it wasn't a directorial note. No,
the cast of The Usual Suspects couldn't
stop laughing because actor Benicio Del Toro
couldn't stop farting. Co-star Kevin Pollak
says he farted on "like 12 takes in a row."
Director Bryan Singer got so mad with the cast's
inability to focus that he yelled at them … which
probably only made them laugh harder.
Speaking of farts, Rain Man is that rare
film that won the Oscar for best picture and also
included one of the most memorable fart scenes in
movie history. Brothers Raymond and Charlie are
in a phone booth together, and Raymond passes gas.
"Uh oh, fart."
"Yeah, Charlie Babbitt, I'll hold."
"Did you fart Ray?"
"Fart."
"How can you stand that?"
"I don't mind."
That was real, and accidental. Stars Dustin
Hoffman and Tom Cruise both managed to stay
completely in character, setting up a
classic moment in cinematic fart history.
One of Django's chief aims in this
2012 Western is to free his wife
from the clutches of terrifyingly crazed
slave owner Calvin Candie. The meeting
between Jamie Foxx's Django and Leonardo
DiCaprio's Calvin is extremely tense,
and for dramatic effect, DiCaprio slams his
hand on a table … and right onto a glass.
"Lay your palm flat on that
tabletop. If you lift those palms
off that turtleshell tabletop, Mr Butch is gonna
let loose with both barrels of that sawed-off!"
DiCaprio didn't stop at all during the take,
even though he just seriously lacerated his hand,
nonchalantly picking out the pieces of
glass and even lighting a cigarette.
Daryl Hannah took home a souvenir
from the set of Blade Runner in the
form of a scar on her arm … and the
take in which she injured it making
its way into the movie. While playing
a replicant named Pris, Hannah ran from
William Sanderson's genetic designer J.F.
Sebastian and slipped on the wet pavement …
Breaking the window wasn't planned,
but Hannah finished filming the scene,
preserving what ended up being a
fairly serious injury for posterity.
For her role as the manipulative outlaw Daisy in
Quentin Tarantino's The Hateful Eight, Jennifer
Jason Leigh had to know how to play a little
guitar. She learned on a vintage 19th century
Martin, on loan to the production from the Martin
Guitar Museum. In one scene, Leigh's co-star Kurt
Russell was supposed to yank the instrument out
of her hands and smash it to smithereens—but
the cameras were supposed to cut first, so it
could be swapped out for an ordinary guitar.
"Music time's over."
"Whoa whoa whoa!"
But the cut didn't come, and Russell
unknowingly destroyed the antique Martin,
valued at $40,000—so Leigh's
reaction is the real thing.
"Whoa whoa whoa!"
James Cameron's 1994 spy comedy contains some
of the biggest and most expensive sequences
in movie history, but the one scene from
True Lies everybody remembers two decades
later is Jamie Lee Curtis's striptease. Her
character, Helen, takes off her clothes for a
man she believes to be an arms dealer, but
is actually her husband, Harry, played by
Arnold Schwarzenegger. Curtis's sexy moment is
interrupted briefly when she loses her balance …
It's a perfect pratfall with impeccable
comic timing, but it wasn't in Cameron's
script. Curtis didn't want to do the scene
the way it was scripted, which called for
her to get completely naked and be filmed in
silhouette. Cameron agreed to her changes,
and they worked out the choreography without
Schwarzenegger's knowledge. So that's a genuine
reaction from Schwarzenegger, who thought the
fall would ultimately just end up as a blooper.
The 1969 low budget classic Midnight Cowboy
features one of the most famous unscripted
lines in movie history. As Dustin Hoffman's Ratso
Rizzo and Jon Voight's Joe Buck are walking across
a very busy and very real Manhattan street having
a conversation, a cab nearly hits Hoffman ...
"Hey, I'm walking here! I'm walking here!"
Hoffman's response was so perfectly in
character that director John Schlesinger
kept it in the film, which went on to
win Best Picture at the Academy Awards.
It's a scene originally meant to serve as just a
transition allowing Woody Allen's proud New Yorker
character Alvy and his girlfriend Annie to mention
they're taking a trip to Los Angeles — but it's
become a classic bit of physical comedy, thanks
to an unplanned moment. A stash of cocaine said
to be worth $2,000 an ounce is passed around
at a party, eventually arriving at Alvy ...
"And what is the kick of it, I never … ACHOO!"
Allen says it was "a complete, unplanned
accident," but test screening audiences
laughed uproariously at it, so Allen, also
the director of the movie, kept it in.